researchers in Germany say they have
proof that a prehistoric teenager had
parents who were members of two
different species of pre humans
scientists used a DNA from ninety
thousand years ago it's in a bone
fragment that was found in Siberia the
tests found that while the girl's mother
was neanderthal her father came from a
recently discovered species the age-old
story really Charlie d'Agata is
following this story in London charlie
good morning good morning to you John
now we all know about the Neanderthals
but what about the Denis Evans not so
much but we now know that they not only
coexisted with the Neanderthals but
apparently got up to a lot more than
that he's the original guy from the
wrong side of the tracks or at least the
other side of this Siberian cave where
the tiny fossils from his 13 year old
daughter were discovered a Neanderthal
Denis 'van lovechild a human hybrid
National Geographic Science Centre is my
away house we've long known that these
kind of mixing happened there's been
hints in both ancient and modern DNA
that suggests that our ancient ancestors
kind of interbred but this is actually
like catching it in the act the DNA was
extracted from a quarter-sized bone
fragment believed to have come from the
teenager who died around 90 thousand
years ago genetic testing revealed a
50/50 split her mother was in the and
earth all who inhabited the western part
of Eurasia but her father was from that
relatively unknown branch of the
prehistoric family the Denisova named
after those siberian caves the results
prove that despite their genetic
differences members of the two groups
mated and raised children one of the
study's authors biologist savant a pay
boat says that's huge I was extremely
surprised I was sure they had screwed
something up in the laboratory
until they prove to me that they hadn't
unlike the Neanderthals little is known
about what the Denis Evans look like all
we know about them was extracted by
scientists from these tiny tooth and
bone fragments we do know they were
genetically linked close enough with the
Neanderthals so that rather than rivals
there were more like kissing cousins now
the author told us the fact that they
were able to just stumble
across the direct offspring suggest our
ancestral cousins probably got up to a
lot more hanky-panky than previously
thought
Noora hanky-panky from Charlie d'Agata
in London thank you always interesting
to learn about our ancestral history
yeah especially something as powerful as
that and then the nice events that needs
to know we have to go back to your 23
night you know you have Siberian in me
who knew